[Music]
last year i published my first book a
memoir called the pyramids
and thanks for coming to my talk how to
write your
memoir um so i'm just going to begin
with one of my favorite quotes about
memoir writing
it's by the author and feminist bell
hooks
i gather together the dreams fantasies
experiences that preoccupied me as a
girl that stay with me and appear and
reappear in different shapes and forms
in all my work
without telling everything that happened
they document all that remains most
vivid
now i love this image of gathering the
notion of going out and collecting those
seeds of passion
of dream and fantasy and trauma that
seeds that make up our stories
and it really stayed with me i had this
quote written up on the wall whilst i
was writing the countless drafts of my
book
and when i say countless i mean
countless
writing a memoir is no easy feat at
least it wasn't for me
and for me i think this was largely
because of two things
the first the very blurry line between
what is fact and what is fiction and the
second
the complexities of writing about
yourself and by extension your community
your family your friends whatever that
means to you
virginia woolf nailed it for me when she
said
here i come to one of the memoir writers
difficulties one of the reasons why
though i read so many so many are
failures
they leave out the person to whom things
happened
what i love so much about the bell hooks
quote i guess is that it embodies the
need explained by wolf
not only not to leave out but also to
gather up
in glorious in a glorious proud and
vivid package
it's a kind of guide or it was for me
how to write about myself with honesty
and integrity
i had to share those most vivid things
that shaped me
and how to do it bravely and without
fear
it took me over ten years to write the
pumi is to navigate my way through the
muddy waters of creative non-fiction
self-exploration self-flagellation
and yet through it all i try to hold on
to that idea of being a gatherer of
collecting all that love and passion
those dreams fantasies experiences
in order to create an end object
a book
this book
i was really determined to write this
book
i didn't know what form it was going to
take i didn't know what it would look
like
i didn't know if it would ever be a
thing an actual real physical thing
and i most certainly didn't know how
hard and long the journey would be
but i think in part it's happened
because i was so determined
or might say obsessed positively
obsessed in the words of sci-fi writer
octavia butler
before i go into why exactly i was so
determined to write and some of the
highs and lows of the whole process
i'll tell you first a little bit about
what the book's about
it started
over 15 years ago on the side of this
road in the bolivian jungle
i was in my early 20s
i was a bit aimless
i'm white and relatively privileged so i
had the luxury of quitting the marketing
job i was doing in london
and because i didn't know what i wanted
to do
i bought a three-month ticket to bolivia
i didn't know much about bolivia it was
in south america it had the highest
proportion of indigenous peoples on the
continent it was the cheapest country to
travel in at that time and it looked
beautiful
i traveled on my own
again a bit aimlessly
volunteering working a bit sightseeing
until about two-thirds into my trip i
was stranded in a tiny town bolivia's
last stop before the amazon proper i
found a flyer for an animal refuge
there was a happy picture of a monkey on
the front and i thought
sure
it was only a six hour ride away
in a local bus
i wasn't that interested in working with
animals but i thought i'd give it a go
i turned up late at night to a
ramshackle jungle camp
i was given a dorm room filled with rats
howling monkeys swung through the trees
and a wild pig rampaged another
volunteer's stolen underwear in her
mouth
there was no internet no electricity no
hot water
i was given a choice
if i committed to staying for a month i
could be assigned to work with a rescue
puma
at that point i didn't really know what
a puma was
mountain lion cougar catamount they were
just these ideas in my head
until the next day
when i was taken out to meet her
wira
her name means wind and quechua
like most of the animals in the
sanctuary she'd been rescued from the
illegal pet trade
her story was similar to most her mother
had been shot by hunters and then she'd
been sold on the black market
she turned up at the sanctuary at 10
months old
when i met her she was three
and she was utterly terrifying at that
point i didn't have the awareness to
understand that she was also terrified
in my eyes she was a hissing starling
puma who i was expected to put on a lead
and walk through the jungle in order to
provide her with daily enrichment
outside of her forested enclosure i was
terrified hot and sweaty bitten by
countless mosquitoes unfit
covered in mud finding cockroaches in my
meals having rats and monkeys crawl over
me at night
i thought i would last 24 hours tops
but
as the days went by at first i was too
tired to consider leaving
but then without even really realizing
it surrounded by those wild animals and
the roar of the jungle
living and working with bolivians with
young people from the local community
working every day in the amazon jungle
with this puma wire
walking with her running with her
chasing monkeys with her napping in the
sun with her for hours on end
helping her be just a little bit wild in
a world that said she could never be
wild again
i started to feel something i'd never
felt before
at least not to this extent
purpose
passion
joy
this puma didn't trust me she yo-yo'd
between hating me and ignoring me
she was so traumatized so terrified of
the world she found herself in
so confused over the fact that she was
meant to be free but didn't have the
skills and abilities to survive on her
own
when the month was over
i stayed i learnt the stories of the
rescued monkeys who howled on the roofs
of the dorms
i learnt the stories of the jaguars and
the other pumas who found their own
homes in the sanctuary and like wira got
walked every day
i learnt the stories of the community
that had created this sanctuary and
welcomed me into their family
wiry grew used to me
months passed
and i missed my flight home
and over time as i began to trust her
she began to trust me
slowly
tentatively
miraculously
i did things i could never have imagined
possible i fought out of control
wildfires with no resources or help just
a desperate desperate group of people
with a few machetes and wet blankets
against the raging infernos that spread
across the sanctuary
i slept on the road under the stars
until the number of logging trucks
increased so much that it wasn't even
safe to walk on that road anymore
i watched hunters pass by with dead
jaguars slung over their motorbikes
i witnessed climate change and
deforestation
and the wreckage consequently wrought on
both human and non-human communities
i spent months wading through neck high
swamps swam side by side with caimans
and anacondas
and squeezed worms eggs out from my skin
and a puma became my best friend
eventually i had to go back to england
but this was the beginning of the love
story that would last for the next 15
years of my life
i stayed that first time for almost two
years in bolivia
when i left it was because i thought i
should
i needed to do something real get a
proper job find a partner settle down be
normal
but the moment i got back to the uk i
knew it was lost
all i wanted to do was get back to
bolivia and to wire
i was heartbroken i'd left behind this
community of strange and tormented
creatures both humans and not
fighting every day for a little piece of
wildness and identity
i worked for six months in order to save
up enough money to return
and during those months
the only thing that really helped me
process what had happened that helped me
put into focus these incredible
experiences i'd had
that helped me realize i was actually
really and truly
head over heels in love with a puma
was to write i spent every day writing
about wira the jungle
the people and animals who become my
family
and not only writing but drawing making
art
trying to catalogue and explain these
feelings i was having that didn't fit
into normal conversation down the pub
oh right so you're in love with the puma
yeah but did you watch bake off this
weekend
wrote the first draft of a memoir
then unsure and full of doubt i turned
it into a novel
i thought it would be easier safer
then i reworked it all over again until
it wasn't quite one or the other
and i put it away in a draw and flew
back to bolivia
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas